[Musik]
wie viele andere uni gemacht da wir
ihnen vielleicht networks sowie im
skispringen und dann muss man sich erst
daran gewöhnen dass das man eben auf
englische anderem unter jenem das tier
das immer wieder spaß machen
vielleicht wird ja von volk und darum
kommt man schnell auf dem boden aber
früher träumte walter steiner davon
fliegen zu können
dann setzte der skispringer zu seinem
schwierigsten sprung an
in ein leben auf dem boden der realität
wie fand der einst umschwärmten star als
bescheidener handwerker sein glück davon
handelt dieser film
[Musik]
in den 70er jahren gehörte walter
steiner zu den besten skispringer der
welt wie kein anderer verkörperte er die
magie dieses sports den traum vom
fliegen
er gewann silber bei olympia wurde
zweimal weltmeister hielt den weltrekord
im skifliegen
[Musik]
auf dem höhepunkt seiner karriere hat er
ein absurdes problem
er sprang zu weit über den kritischen
punkt der schanze hinaus um stürze wie
diesen zu vermeiden verkürzte er
freiwillig seinen online so etwas hatte
es noch nie gegeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seine bewunderer gaben dem toggenburger
den übernamen vogelmensch aber immer
schön und um hätte karriere
aufmerksamkeit über konter
niedergetreten haben wir zu einem zum
hals aus dass man jetzt erstmal kein
dann die man muss antwort beginn um
vielleicht noch ein paar jahre wenn
jemand noch mehr fragen
seit man vielleicht viel wärmer wird
wird will letztendlich dann machen wir
jetzt der film ja ich hoffe dass sie
schweizerdeutsch überhaupt noch richtig
antworten walter steiner arbeitet im
gebäude unterhalt für die schwedische
landeskirche
der universal handwerker ist zuständig
für sechs kirchen und versammlungs
gebäude seit über 20 jahren lebt der
schweizerin vor allem im süden von
schweden
sport ist noch immer sein wichtigster
lebens in der 64 jährige hat es an die
weltspitze der langlauf senioren
geschafft wie schon als skispringer
arbeitet der leidenschaftliche tüftler
mit kuriosen methoden weil seine lungen
leistung nicht mehr die beste ist setzt
er beim langlaufen nur die arme ein
so verbrauche er weniger sauerstoff auf
mit den großen muskeln der beine
verrückt aber erfolgreich 40 jahre nach
seinen triumphen auf der sprungschanze
gewinnt walter stein an der diesjährigen
wm in russland gleich drei medaillen
johann im ihn machst dich und jetzt
natürlich als langläufer mini 20 paraden
betreuer aber da sind auch von meinem
freund war mir über meine ganze karriere
so zeigt bürger gemacht hat wo alle
jahre nicht aktiv die babys die ironie
denn in amerika city und da für mich
wunderbar ist seine klasse und zurückzog
um ihre karriere
der benefit lehrer als holzbildhauer und
das ist für mich und für die lehrmeister
von beschwert sie will so hat die
absenzenliste also wir haben bis zum 27
gedeck see und business class auf erfolg
sicher 1974 startete walter steiner an
der wm in vollen seine heutigen heimat
[Musik]
werde ich das was ich wisst ihr wo
stehst 71 und ihre spätere frau ja das
sieht warum herzklappen
ja das hat wunderbar geklappt die
wunderschöne zeit aber ist am schluss
wieder brander noch könne sie bedrucken
und dann hat im film von mir hatten am
schluss kunst und jetzt lebt ihr
zusammen und sind gut
aber schmerzlich wenn er einen freund
ein frau sei absolut negativ wie so
dankbar weil ich will dass sie glücklich
ist glücklich dass sie ist wieder das
haben die firma bauer und wenn es
überhaupt einfach nur klappert denn man
hätte kachelmann muss richtig denn ist
das beste so das ist genial
italien hier doch es ist also der brief
braucht will dass der vor wm sieht daher
keine medaillen überall
1978 beendete walter steiner seine
karriere
er arbeitete als trainer in der schweiz
und in den usa
1990 kam als sprungschanzen experte nach
schweden
seit der scheidung und walter steiner am
stadtrand das traumhaus am see überließ
es einen extra
walter steiner ist nicht gerade ein
lebemann jeden aspekt seiner asketischen
lebensort er der gesundheit unter er
bildete sich weiter in massage
kinesiologie und alternativer ernährung
einige jahre arbeitete er als diätkoch
in einem sanatorium
er kocht ohne salz unter herd bleibt
fast immer kalt und ruhe für äpfel dann
natürlich auch noch studieren salat
paprika war jeden tag frische gar
integrieren hätte wunderbare weltkrieg
auf die körper und dort sowohl maric und
alles zum beispiel in der medizin hat
man immer wieder cayenne drin jetzt auf
die ganzkörper verteilt und das hat
nicht gelernt dass wir mädels verletzten
diese schnitte hat mir niemand zweifel
seien im wasser aufgelöst und
infektionen betroffen
jetzt werden wir sehen wie viele sagen
dass ein spiel der roten teppich
zusammen die man ist ja wort pc
engagieren aber nur mensch programmiert
wurde verboten und und blätter und zum
teil auch natürlich sogar dafür ist wohl
ein anderes fleisch braucht man sich
hier kochen und ihr hochwertiges
nahrungsmittel ist die größte verstört
lichteffekt wenn man durch das beste
hitze das weiß man so lange flüstert
doktor bücher allein das verstanden die
zivilisation gott ein anderer weg und da
war das schafft der natur wächst da wir
ganz ruhig belohnt schluss das ist jetzt
das doping für langlauf der vogelmensch
ist ein sympathischer couch ein
eigenbrötler ein tüftler ein kämpfer mit
hohen ansprüchen und idealen
er ist immer in bewegung ungeduldig und
rastlos
um seine ziele zu erreichen scheut
keinen aufwand mit seinem freund michael
kämpft er sich vor der wm durch
stundenlange trainingseinheiten ist ein
bisschen eigenartig oder wie wir in
schweden sagen ein nerd das trifft es
wohl am besten
er ist ich finde gar kein englisches
wort
es gibt kein wort um ihn zu beschreiben
auch schwedisch heißt das inwis
schauen sie haben dinge dass lumpen sie
mit dem zufall sondern alles versuchen
perfekt machen
ja
und den opel-plänen bodybuilder noch
weniger wäre lebensbedrohlich bei
spitzensportlern gilt den
körperfettanteil von rund zehn prozent
als normal
walter steiner die ausnahmeerscheinung
in der schweiz konnte er sich kam frei
bewegen
alle erkannten den schweden lässt man
ihn in ruhe
da muss ich sagen ob das das ich aus
person
wie wäre es damit so unheimlich sozial
dass sie habe von der close blau.de nur
damit ich doch nicht wahr das ist eine
mini mentalität des volkes und erzählen
und wissen wo wir nicht mehr so stickig
aber dann findet in uster johanna
türlich und vor allem soll die kamera
hätten wo man im sport und zu der natur
wenn er mittlerweile als fester die
absolute person ich für mich zum film
haben wie viel wissen die menschen in
folge über walter steiners früheres
leben
ich denke nur ganz wenige kennen seine
geschichte
hier weiß man nicht wer er ist
ich habe gehört in der schweiz sehr
berühmt hier in falun nicht
[Musik]
ich habe erfolg selbst seine
arbeitskolleginnen und -kollegen staunen
als sie sehen dass sich das schweizer
fernsehen für ihren walter interessiert
steiner hat sich ein neues leben
aufgebaut weit weg vom ehemaligen ruhm
aus skispringen sein schwierigster
sprung ist ihm gelungen
er landete ohne sturz im auto geblieben
sind die hohen ansprüche an sich selbst
steiner erledigt seine aufgaben als
hauswart mit der gleichen hingabe wie
für seine sprünge
ja ist er für schnitzel das sage ich da
im 16
helfer machen als das profil am anderer
der lediglich hat es ist stockmann als
schnitzmeister das profil macht ja das
schönste kanzler hatte sich schnitzler
walter steiner ist legastheniker weil
dies auf dem arbeitsmarkt ein hindernis
ist zahlt der schwedische staat die
hälfte seines lohns aus einem
förderungsfonds bei der kirche landete
er zufällig die hand mit dem eigenen
glauben mag seine familie wollen wir
wenigstens gibt es dich geborgen und
controller unterricht langen natürlich
und haben einfach die gute aspekt vom
glauben könne mit mehr also das was mir
fehlt die routine und meinem sport
verbände
obwohl er sich nicht so dass hier jetzt
ende gar nicht können immer die kirche
und glaube kann man auch und mit
grillgut aber das ist mir nicht fremd
[Applaus]
und besucht menschen am schluss selber
machen ich war selbst besucht um ihr
selber gestaltet und alles was der
mensch macht ich meine ich oft nicht gut
so
februar 2015
von walter steines haustür findet die
nordisch wm statt
er besucht den grossanlass als
gewöhnlicher zu schauen
die sportfans erkennen ihn nicht
interessant macht ihn lediglich die
fernsehkamera
vor 37 jahren sprang hier zum letzten
mal selber heute verfolgte die springen
von der betreuer tribüne aus der
perfektionist zog sich schon früh aus
dem organisationskomitee zurück zu viele
details an der schanze genügten seinen
ansprüchen nicht
[Musik]
der 64-jährige ist hier eine ikone wie
weit bist du damals in planitz
angesprungen über 180 und 1 169
[Musik]
bei den noch weiteren stürzte ich
steiner konzentriert sich auf den
sekundenbruchteil in dem der springer
vom schanzentisch abhebt
da entscheide sich alles und natürlich
fiebert er mit als der andere
weltberühmte toggenburger springt
[Applaus]
heute ist nicht simon ammanns tag bin
ich aber nicht ich höre ich habe die
bücher und ich ja schaut
die besten sprünge seien ihm sowieso nie
auf der schanze gelungen sagt walter
steiner
für den traum vom fliegen braucht man
keine sie an den füßen liefern also
keine angst geherrscht und über die
stecken haben im traum und zum
ausfliegen und immer und immer wieder
den hang ist eine schwerelose und dann
immer denkt noch eine brache bedenken
wenn ich ein dem skispringen so flüge
nach der flüge aber nicht sehen konnte
also ist los war letztendlich zeigen
geschwindigkeit über die wahl aus
[Musik]